hello everyone I'm Alana with Charles
and welcome to my channel and today I am
catching up on just a couple of trailers
from last week's state of play I was in
Vegas for a game developers conference
called dice which I go to every year and
I absolutely love this so many
Fascinating People and so much to learn
about video games there but it did mean
that I missed out on the state of play
um based on the PlayStation YouTube
channel I just picked the two trailers
that really stood out to me the most but
if you think that there were any of the
smaller games
um that I should really check out that
you thought were cool please do let me
know in the comments and I'll make sure
I check up on those but
for now we are going to watch Resident
Evil 4 this is the third trailer and The
Suicide Squad killed the Justice League
two games I feel very very differently
about I am extremely excited about the
re4 Remake I'm not so sure about suicide
squad so I'm going into this one
I guess I'm hoping to see um
maybe a little bit more combat some
scares we've had I feel like the other
trailers have been a bit more tone
focused so I would love to see more
action orientated
um I guess some some of the insight to
how some of the characters have changed
because it looks like that's going to be
a thing so that's what I'm looking for
here Suicide Squad is a whole other
story but we'll get to that so to start
with this trailer is only two minutes
and 28 seconds so
pretty quick I'm so excited for this
game
you see we are all connected through the
holy body
we need only accept the sacred gift oh
man
she did this genuinely looks really
scary already
the animation oh my God that's creepy
I don't make a cheat for you move
it's always like this with you I like
the vibe of these two it's like throwing
out
it's crazy how similar
so many different pieces of different re
games all to to fall like just how
iconic it was oh cool we are just
getting attacked anyone
what's gonna happen with me
you gotta keep moving forward it's so
good I hate this it's very pretty
together
[Music]
loving the voice cast as well
hurt yourself I love him so much
[Music]
this is kind of fun
very like cute
kidding ah yes the time has come
oh interesting combat looks
a bit different to the other remix yeah
for sure
this time
it has to be different
dude love it I love how this looks like
oh nice
can't wait
special demo coming soon you can better
be playing that
um love it
this is this trailer is a very good vibe
of like things that genuinely look very
scary it's like I almost forgot that
Resident Evil 4 is a horror game
because playing it now the older
versions
it's not as scary because of the aspect
um or at least the fixed camera at least
to me
that's why I love these remakes so much
I'm so happy with the remix but this
also has a lot of like fun Charming
personality
um especially because of Lewis I think
which is just so nice to see uh
definitely like a ton of Personality
yeah I love this trailer let's see what
the internet thought huh
because sometimes I
tend to land on the friendly side of
trailers
nope I absolutely wholehearted love the
idea of getting to see Leon and Lewis
Gold Body come together I'm so excited
totally agree that I think I might have
even said that 100
you know when I heard they were remaking
re4 I was terrified because it was such
a classic that I didn't want it to be
ruined but this is looking amazing also
agree with that like I know a lot of
people were worried about this I think I
might have even felt that way initially
um I don't remember I'd have to go watch
my first reaction but
this looks really good to me
this looks completely true to the
original with added twists more details
the added twist thing is the thing that
I think I love about this too is it
doesn't
look exactly the same so I'm excited to
see what they've changed and what they
haven't changed rifle is a very good
very iconic game but it's not
necessarily perfect
um
do you agree that turning a masterpiece
to change the gaming industry to yet
another must be to change the standard
for remix I totally agree with this
comment as well
can't get over how beautiful the game
looks 100 percent
absolute Masterpiece people really
thrown that word around tall
it's too loving that um Leon solos
everything I like the difference I think
it's really fun but it also means that
we have like two different versions of
the game
it made me more excited about it the fun
silly vibe
Resident Evil full original Resident
Evil in general right now just
absolutely popping off love to see okay
the second trailer we have for today is
a little bit long it says six minutes of
Suicide Squad kill the Justice League
official co-op gameplay so I guess this
is just actual gameplay here
um
this one
I love Rocksteady the studio behind uh
Suicide Squad um I'm a very big fan of
all the Arkham games
but for some reason this hasn't appealed
to me quite so much and I've been a
little bit
um concerned about the cob aspect of it
and I feel that way about a lot of games
right now like I'm a really big fan of
Arcane and I don't love that red Falls
seems to have such a combat sorry such a
co-op Focus
um
so
I don't know suicide squad's one that
I'm like open to
but currently not excited and I'm always
I'm always very positively about video
games I always hope that
um this is the trailer that's going to
change my mind it's gonna blow me away
um I know I felt really negatively about
Gotham Knights back when it was first
announced and if you go look at my
initial reaction to that trailer people
are like really harsh in the comments
being like oh you've been so negative
what's wrong with you but I feel like I
was sort of Justified in that
um
not you know it's not like I hate
anything or want anything to be bad I
can just kind of be a little bit um
get a critical I suppose so I really I
want I want to be sold on this one
let's do it
I do love king shark as a character big
fan
oh you know what
hold on a sec hello Brainiac
is it happening now
great you will have Luther ASAP
not Luther all you have to do is
look I think the premise is really fun
The Suicide Squad premise in general has
always been fun
graphically coming right next to um
though
are we clear yeah
time to light them all up
kind of looks like Saints rope
what was it for like the one where you
basically play as a superhero
yeah I'd love to see more postcards
combat because that's the thing that
like that and the stealth that we end up
loving Rock City so much for and it's
gonna be hard for them to
get be stuck in this particular
it looks like
the vibe is just very like
Saints Row fortnite kind of I wonder if
they're inspired by the success in
fortnite
I have no doubt that it will be a ton of
fun to play Club they always are
again I really do love King shaka's
character huge fan
just think he's the coolest I really
like sharks man
it does look like a pretty impressive
open world
certainly a lot more density than the
recent Saints Road
Unstoppable
thank you
I feel like this is probably longer than
it needed to be and then I'm already
like okay I get it
this one won't die already
[Music]
I wonder if we get like um
a co-op combo finishing type stuff
I mean the scale of this is impressive
for something Co-op but I just keep
being like well
having lasers pointed at you while you
shoot a glowy thing it's not a
particularly New Concept
though how the hole taking down the
flash thing go
she must be so fun to voice Act
play
and get out of my way I have work to do
well hey there's
we've got an interrogation to get back
to yeah the concept of like having to
take down these big guys is super fun
you think I'm just like they could be
very interesting
and tell these guys everything you know
you think they can stop us
pathetic
at least I'm not a big hero turn stooge
for a space man
your hero can
do I'll show you
flash how do I stop this
oh Wonder Woman tell me cow
I like how design will look
you careless Diana
whoa that line hits on
damn to save the world
the boss fights could be really cool but
then they should have shown one I think
so
um that gave me chills at the end though
um which is awesome
and I think that I
I love the concept concept wise sorry
combat wise
it's not that I think it looks bad I
just feel like it's not really my kind
of thing it's sort of a preference that
I don't love the like again very sort of
fortnighty look floaty
um characters with with guns I tend to
really like um a melee focused game
across the board and that's why I love
the Arkham Series so much
um I think I prefer things that are a
little bit closer quarters unless it's a
first person shooter I can like a third
person shooter if it's really tactical
so it's kind of the combination of the
guns and the floatiness and I'm I'm just
personally not a huge fan of
which is a bummer
um yeah let's see how everyone else
feels about it get a feeler if I'm alone
on this so
cutscenes legit look more exciting and
interesting than gameplay
I agree I did think that cutscene looked
really good oh this is super comforting
okay honestly my excitement of this game
has dropped so much today it looks like
another person shooter
I agree
what I like most of Hope stays in the
game's level interaction between the
characters rather than Bland AI
interactions I hope we see more joking
and taking in the team in the game I
agree with that damn I guess everybody
feels that way huh I really was like
it's probably just me and I'm gonna get
a bunch of people be really mad at me
for having a negative take on it
so
bad it just looks very
um it's not for me I'm sure there's a
massive market for this game and I'm
sure it will still be successful because
it's like it looks like it's like Co-op
DC Fortnight like there's gonna be a ton
of people that love this the game
doesn't look bad I don't think
it's just not my style
um
so I ultimately was hoping that this
trailer would sell me on the game but it
is sort of done the opposite it's made
me less excited which is a massive
bummer
um
so yeah I guess like I did have two
different anticipations going into
watching this today and I come out with
two very different takes which is so
goddamn excited for Resident Evil
I don't know that I will play Suicide
Squad now which
maybe it's just me